vous avez connaissez macron vous avez un
talent c'est lourd pour arriver à part
les sept minutes je suis incapable de
résumer votre pensée je n'ai rien dit et
j'ai encore parlé à peine séparée - et
sidérale fait incroyable et moi je tiens
l'attention des français quand même je
voudrais quand même que ils s'attachent
à vérifier que à chaque fois que vous
prenez la parole vous dit un petit peu
de ceci un petit peu de cela et jamais
vous ne trancher on ne sait pas ce que
vous voulez bon je sais pas ce que vous
voulez c'est très et honnêtement je
trouve ça très intéressant vous n'avez
pas compris rezaï qu'elle avoue je ne
veux pas pactiser avec monsieur poutine
si vous n'avez pas compris que
contrairement à vous je veux une
politique française forte mais
responsable c'est à dire vers le
ruisseau à l'élégance qu'on ne sait pas
financer comme ça vous aurez compris que
comme contrairement à vous je propose
d'avoir une france forte dans une europe
que j'assume pleinement c'est notre
grand des actions européens se réduit
mais c'est notre désaccord donc quand on
n'est pas d'accord avec vous on peut
être clair alors c'est sûr qu'on n'est
pas d'accord il ya beaucoup de français
qui ne sont pas d'accord avec vous